elle se niche au coeur du quartier
l'épicerie des nardol c'est un peu le
lieu de rencontre des riverains et des
passants
c'est ici à pelletier que l'on se
retrouve que l'on échange et que l'on
craint surtout faire quelques courses
c'est important à cette tranquille de
son amante en europe apace a commencé
j'aime tous les samedis oui ça biloa les
quais ou ville entend tuer ou la boue
séchée et c'était lisieux après 110
mangova devant pas des habitués auxquels
sont venus se greffer de nouveaux
clients durant le confinement mais
aujourd'hui chacun a repris ses
habitudes semble-t-il on a eu beaucoup
plus de clients que d'habitude mais ça
reste bon c'est resté éphémère pense que
en définitive après après le virus donc
toutes les choses reprennent
on va dire leur place mais heureusement
grâce à une offre de produits variés
l'épicier du quartier parvient à toucher
une large clientèle des acheteurs à la
recherche de produits du quotidien mais
aussi de convivialité
c'est un lien social c'est un lieu de
rencontre c'est un endroit où on peut
échanger discuter pas seulement pas
seulement acheter puis qu'ils ont mais
la plupart du temps il ya des clients
après avoir acheté une ou deux bien
mauvaise neuf ans le magasin ou discuter
avec leurs amis et le petit plus c'est
le pain frais libre et chaque matin par
le boulanger
j'ai comme ça moi sinon je n'ai pas
hésité jargon toujours pas s'ils
prennent pas la peine ils ont leur
boulangerie
en 2009 les épiceries avaient déjà rendu
de grands services à la population
ils ont encore répondu présent durant le
confinement
pourtant elles tendent à disparaître
face à la concurrence des supermarchés
à nous de ne pas oublier ses boutiques
emblématique de nos quartiers